paraguay está atravesando una nueva ola
de contagio de kobe 19 que está
sacudiendo el sistema sanitario público
y privado ya son más de 200.000 los
contagios y 4000 las muertes por la
enfermedad hace más de un mes el país
está batiendo continuamente su récord de
contagio y muertes diarias y el gobierno
atribuye este aumento acelerado a que la
variante brasileña del virus que es más
infecciosa ya está circulando de forma
comunitaria en distintos puntos del país
con una ocupación del 100 por ciento de
camas de terapia el presidente mario
abdo benítez decidió decretar una nueva
cuarentena durante la semana santa con
el objetivo de disminuir los contagios y
descomprimir los hospitales a todo esto
hay que sumar que el país mantiene uno
de los peores registros de vacunación en
todo el continente apenas 36 mil
personas fueron vacunadas contra el coi
y 19 en paraguay para contrarrestar este
déficit el gobierno aceptó una donación
de 100 mil dosis de la vacuna coec sinde
india sin embargo esto generó nuevas
críticas a la administración de abdo
benítez debido a que esta vacuna aún no
tiene el aval de una entidad regulatoria
internacional y por lo tanto no será
administrada todavía la población
paraguaya